All right, I'll go step first.
Oh, that's thumbnail.
Come on. No, you're in the middle, Powers. You're still in the middle.
Ooh.
Alex, you can't let him off easy.
He's got to redeem himself.
Ah, it's looking good, guys.
Hell yeah.
There's no rhyme or reason here.
Yellow card.
No shame in the man.
Dude, I feel like it's better than it was, than it's been in the last few.
Bigger progress the first step.
Like I would normally run.
Yeah, yeah, something like that.
Come on.
And then if you need to slow the feet.
Nice hands.
Let's finish. Let's finish.
Nice. Good ball. Good timing.
Nice, Joe. Way to dummy.
Shit, I want the ball, damn it.
Go, go.
Ready, Trevor?
Whoever you want. Your choice.
Right here.
Let's do it.
Nice.
Now, there you go.
You got it, I got it, I got it!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
Yeah.
Oh, Kenny.
Yep!
Nice try, Kenny.
Hey.
Never a shot.
Oh, fuck you, Kenny.
Come on, good game.
Good.
I think he's a little dizzy out there.
Yeah, Harry, I'm holding, man.
I'm all day!
Nice, guys.
All right, guys.
Can we pitch now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, guys.
That's a nice finish.